tras una jornada de mensajes de
advertencia sobre las consecuencias
devastadoras del cambio climático en la
cob 26 más de 100 líderes mundiales se
comprometieron a detener la
deforestación para el año 2030 el pacto
será firmado el martes sin embargo
muchos de los objetivos anunciados por
países como brasil ecuador o india nos
suman lo suficiente
la corte suprema de eeuu escuchó
argumentos contra la ley antiaborto de
textos dos meses después de que entrara
en vigor sin ser refutada por el máximo
tribunal los servicios de aborto tienen
esperanza pues dos de los jueces
conservadores reconsideran su postura
iniciales sobre la norma que penaliza la
interrupción del embarazo desde la sexta
semana
y la industria turística mejora sus
perspectivas detrás ser una de las más
golpeadas por la pandemia de kobe 19
este lunes argentina-uruguay israelí
tailandia relajaron sus restricciones de
acceso a extranjeros vacunados la
reapertura también llegó a australia
principalmente para ciudadanos y
residentes permanentes
un cordial saludo mi nombre es ángela
gómez y volvemos con más noticias aquí
en france 24 iniciamos con la cumbre del
clima con 26 porque hoy se conoció el
primer acuerdo del evento más de 100
líderes mundiales se comprometieron a
detener y revertir la deforestación y la
degradación de la tierra esto para
finales de la década una promesa que
debe concretarse en 2030 y será
financiada con 19 mil millones de
dólares en fondos públicos y privados
para invertir en la protección y en la
restauración de los bosques brasil
indonesia y la república democrática del
congo hacen parte de los firmantes en
conjunto a los adheridos a la iniciativa
reúnen el 85% de los bosques del mundo
y también en la primera jornada de la
cob 26 líderes latinoamericanos
estuvieron presentes con sus discursos
brasil se comprometió a reducir sus
emisiones de carbono como anunció su
presidente en un vídeo pregrabado y
ecuador- anunció la protección de su
biodiversidad en las islas galápagos sin
embargo en la región la defensa del
medio ambiente sigue causando la muerte
sistemática de activistas climáticos
marina sardiña trae un resumen de la
jornada
metas más ambiciosas en la primera
jornada de la cob 26 líderes
latinoamericanos expusieron sus nuevos
objetivos contra el calentamiento global
el presidente ultraderechista brasileños
se comprometió a reducir un 50% las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
hasta 2030
juegos favores vamos a favorecer las
acciones y proyectos de conservación de
los bosques el uso racional de los
recursos naturales la mitigación de las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
y sobre todo la creación de empleos
verdes generación siempre bus viernes si
bien bolsonaro mostró a su país como un
garante en el compromiso medioambiental
evitó hablar de la deforestación de la
amazonía con su llegada al poder la
amazonía brasileña sufrió su peor
deforestación desde 2008 aumentando un
25 por ciento sólo en este año por ello
una activista brasileña indígena apeló
al papel crucial de las comunidades
nativas en la protección de la
biodiversidad
verde tengamos las mentiras vacías y las
promesas falsas acabemos con la
contaminación de las palabras huecas y
luchemos por un futuro y un presente
visibles presente por su parte ecuador
anunció nuevas medidas proteger 60 mil
kilómetros cuadrados de delicados
ecosistemas marinos la declaratoria de
una nueva reserva marina en galápagos
provocará
que se realicen propuestas
financieras
de canje de deuda por conservación para
la primera ministra de barbados el
incumplimiento de los países ricos de su
promesa de dar 100 mil millones de
dólares anuales a los países del sur
global tienen consecuencias mortales
fernando la falta de financiación
crítica y la de pérdidas y daños en mi
de amigos míos en vidas y medios de vida
en nuestras comunidades
esto es inmoral e injusto
américa latina es la región más letal
para los defensores y líderes
medioambientales según el último informe
de la ong global witness que advierten
que la lucha climática pasa también por
la protección de las comunidades nativas
y sus líderes noticias de eeuu desde hoy
la corte suprema- escuchó los argumentos
contra la ley antiaborto de textos que
penaliza la interrupción del embarazo
desde la sexta semana de gestación
cuando muchas mujeres ni siquiera tienen
conocimiento de su estado
la prohibición entró en vigencia hace
dos meses impulsada por los publicanos
del estado y en septiembre la corte la
había dejado pasar pero en esta segunda
revisión solicitada por el gobierno de
joe biden los servicios de aborto tienen
esperanza pues dos magistrados
conservadores están reconsiderando sus
posiciones y podrían cambiar la balanza
entre los nueve del tribunal detalles
desde washington con nuestro
corresponsal cristóbal vázquez
la corte suprema de eeuu escuchó hoy los
argumentos del departamento de justicia
y de los proveedores de aborto en este
país en su demanda contra el estado de
texas que permitió una ley que prohíbe
el aborto después de seis semanas
incluso en caso de violación o incesto
la mayoría de los jueces de la corte
suprema se mostraron en favor de revisar
la ley de este estado porque ésta
bloquea de manera inapropiada según
ellos la revisión judicial necesaria
cuando los derechos constitucionales
están en cuestión entre los jueces que
se inclinaron por la revisión de esta
ley antiaborto de texas están recabando
y emi con ibergrid que son de tendencia
conservadora y fueron nombrados por
donaldson los demandantes argumentan que
ninguna ley constitucional o precedente
de la corte suprema está segura si la
instancia judicial máxima en eeuu se
pone del lado de texas porque esta ley
contra el aborto se salta procesos
constitucionales y podría terminar
abriendo una caja de pandora para que
otros estados pues se terminen
saltándose derechos constitucionales
como por ejemplo el porte de armas en
noticias desde la pandemia la cifra de
fallecidos porque hoy 19 superó 5
millones a nivel global la lista es
encabezada por eeuu seguido de brasil e
india- sin embargo si se revisan los
decesos relativos a la población pero
queda en lo alto de la clasificación un
año y medio después de que la oms se
decretara la emergencia las
desigualdades entre países la fortaleza
de los sistemas de salud y los ritmos de
vacunación han marcado la recuperación
vamos al análisis con el doctor
francisco moreno sánchez médico
internista e infectólogo responsable del
programa kobe 19 en el centro médico abc
de mexico doctor gracias a usted por
estar con nosotros y sonia muchísimas
vidas perdidas desde que inició la
crisis sanitaria que indicadores han
marcado la curva de fallecimientos y ya
con vacunas que van hasta en terceras
dosis y en dosis de refuerzo que podemos
esperar en adelante
pues desafortunadamente los números son
increíbles cuando pensamos que en el
2019 pudiera haber una pandemia que se
causara en menos de dos años al menos
cinco millones de fallecidos porque
sabemos que el número es real de acuerdo
al exceso de mortalidad
habla de cerca de 19 millones de
fallecidos en el mundo por esta
enfermedad
como lo comentan bien las diferencias en
cuanto a los problemas de salud de
diferentes países de países que no han
tenido no tienen una capacidad de
tratamiento para esta enfermedad en
particular que requiere terapia
intensiva medicina crítica y
especialistas en terapia respiratoria
pues ha marcado la diferencia en el
mundo
y son además cinco millones oficialmente
los fallecidos por kobe d pero ahí no se
incluyen los millones de muertos por
otros padecimientos o por otras crisis
que se descuidaron con la llegada del
nuevo corona virus como asumen los
sistemas de salud todos los huecos en
atención y en presupuesto para otras
enfermedades
si esto ha causado un rezago en salud a
nivel global porque desafortunadamente
por temor por falta de lugar falta de
espacio muchas de las enfermedades
crónicas degenerativas que son muy
frecuentes en américa latina' por
ejemplo en méxico somos el segundo país
con el mayor índice de obesidad con una
alta prevalencia de diabetes e
hipertensión y estas enfermedades
crónico-degenerativas también fueron
desatendidas durante la pandemia pues
por necesidades de camas hospitalarias y
también por el miedo de los propios
pacientes a acudir a sus atenciones de
rutina esto es un problema que
evidentemente va a tener una
trascendencia en los meses y si no es
que en los años que van a venir y para
finalizar le quiero preguntar año y
medio después o cuáles son las lecciones
aprendidas de esta pandemia
tenemos que aprender algo creo que eso
es lo más importante el ser humano es
vulnerable creo que estamos más
preocupados por la economía la política
y nos habíamos olvidado de la salud
tanto individual y en muchos países como
en el mío méxico de la salud en cuanto a
la atención de la población también
tenemos que entender que hay que
adaptarnos a los cambios que
desafortunadamente esta enfermedad
requiere que usted es una mascarilla
para cubrirte la cara cuando las
saludables cerrados necesitas vacunarse
necesitas adaptarte al cambio y la gente
que no se ha adaptado al cambio no
solamente pone en riesgo su vida sino
los demás tenemos que aprender que hay
que ser solidarios y solidarios como
como mundo porque también la
distribución de vacunas
desafortunadamente también ha sido muy
inequitativa muchísimas gracias a
ustedes y seguimos con más noticias el
turismo internacional respira
argentina-uruguay israelã de tailandia y
australia relajaron restricciones
generando optimismo en las instituciones
turísticas de que viene cerca la vuelta
de los viajeros detalles en el siguiente
informe de luís muñoz
y aplausos
y danza este lunes volvieron los
turistas a uruguay deberán estar
totalmente inmunizados al menos 15 días
antes del vuelo todos los fármacos
actualmente disponibles serán aceptados
el gobierno pondrá 500.000 vacunas para
los que quieran una dosis de refuerzo y
para los menores de 12 a 18 años que
pueden ingresar al país sin vacuna el
mundo hoy de alguna manera nos está
mirando como uno de los países que puede
recibir turismo sano y como tal vamos a
estar a la altura de sus expectativas
una reapertura que se extiende por el
río de la plata argentina también
reabrió este lunes sus fronteras para
turistas igual que uruguay los
visitantes deberán estar totalmente
vacunados en este caso 14 días antes del
vuelo que el turismo extranjero le da
ese plus económico a nuestro país en
materia turística que no te lo da que
tal vez en otros segmentos de detecta
actividad también hubo reapertura en
israel 20 meses después sólo podrán
entrar aquellos que hayan recibido la
segunda o tercera dosis seis meses antes
del viaje
cuando una persona se da cuenta de que
tiene dinero extra ahí es cuando viaja y
piensa en el turismo pero dado que la
economía mundial ha retrocedido es poco
probable
también tailandia ha eliminado las
cuarentenas para viajeros ahora para
entrar tendrán que estar vacunados pasan
una noche en un hotel y recibir una
prueba negativa un signo de esperanza en
un país que en 2019 había recibido 40
millones de visitantes
spacey con la corona me tuvo alejado de
tailandia durante 18 meses y un año de
mi esposa hoy que ha sido el primer día
de reapertura he aprovechado para volver
a la normalidad que también está más
cerca en australia uno de los países con
las políticas fronterizas más estrictas
sus ciudadanos y residentes permanentes
podrán salir y volver al país sin
cuarentenas sin embargo los turistas
extranjeros a excepción de los de nueva
zelanda aún deberán esperar
y en otros temas de cara a la
celebración del día de los muertos en
méxico vamos al estado de campeche para
hablar de la tradición milenaria que se
mantiene viva la limpieza de los santos
restos óseos consiste en exhumar y
limpiar los huesos de los seres queridos
fallecidos y se considera un ritual que
es un acto de amor el informe desde
catia espinoza
[Música]
desde hace dos años se deben realizar la
limpieza de los huesos de su hermano
mario en los días previos a la
celebración de los fieles difuntos los
usuarios se pintan y los familiares
sacan un baúl en el que han depositado
los restos de sus fallecidos con una
brocha va limpiando uno a uno los huesos
de los que ya no están físicamente como
acto de amor más que nada porque
en un ejemplo cuando tú tienes a un
familiar
que no puede valerse por sí
y tú haces todo lo posible para que él
se vea bien y pueda salir es un ritual
milenario que se realiza en el estado
mexicano de campeche y se llama limpieza
de los santos restos socios los restos
de las personas que fallecen son
exhumados tres años después de su muerte
y son depositados en un baúl sobre una
manta especial que los familiares se
encargan a las bordadoras de la
localidad el proceso como mayormente
pues a tiempo muchos lo conocemos es la
limpieza de los pies hacia la cabeza
porque sabemos que terrenal mente en las
personas en vida palpamos el mundo
exterior por los pies por la tierra
entonces ellos al regresar tienen que
entrar caminando además de la limpieza
de huesos las fotos de los difuntos se
exhiben en plazas públicas y en las
casas donde se levantan altares
decorados con platillos bebidas y
objetos que los difuntos amaban en vida
es una costumbre que se hereda hay
algunos elementos gráficos en algunos
libros que firmaban los en comendador es
por ahí de mil 637 mil seiscientos mil
siete entre mil seis mil setecientos
donde narran justamente en algunos
escritos que hay pueblos donde
acostumbran a hacer la limpieza de estos
de las osamentas para los mayas la
muerte solo era un ciclo más en el
universo un reencuentro con sus dioses y
en estas fechas el regreso con el mismo
permiso de sus dioses para volver al
plano terrenal al menos por unos días
hasta aquí el informativo siguen
france24
[Música]